yeah well I mean it seems like we all
agree that life is a game so there's not
going to be any screaming back and forth
I guess
um I mean what do you mean by this what
do we mean by game yeah
[Music]
yeah I think what I said earlier was
there are many games that we can be
playing and I think the most important
games are the ones where we're kind of
in competition with ourself uh vying for
things that aren't necessarily shared
with other people or that other people
are competing for I don't see any reason
why for instance every person couldn't
reach some baseline Proficiency in
mental health and physical health and
strength and even level of educational
attainment it doesn't even have to be
formal College in the pursuit of some
hobby or passion like these are all
types of games that people can play that
can enrich their lives in a plethora of
ways I think that the issue that we run
into especially in the western world is
a lot of the games that we're looking to
play are in competition with other
people there's a saying that um is it
jealousy is the thief of Joy or like
like the idea that basically you can
have something you can be nice and feel
good about it but then as you see that
your neighbor has something bigger or
better now all of a sudden you don't
feel good about the thing you have you
know you have the iPhone 12 he's got the
iPhone 13 you have the Mustang he's got
the Bugatti that all of a sudden the
things that you have are no longer good
anymore
I think that the the games as I said
earlier the games that we play seem to
be increasingly more consumeristic and a
consumer game is often measured by the
the actual value dollar amount of the
things that you're acquiring and in that
sense it's very easy to compare from A
to B is my house worth more than his
house is my car worth more than his
house am I in the top ten percent five
percent or one percent of earners I
think that if you're stuck on playing
these games where you're in Relentless
competition with other people then
necessarily you're going to have winners
and losers and necessarily there's going
to be a big chunk of losers that are
going to feel like losers and it's going
to inhibit even their ability to
navigate life and play the individual
games that I think they should be more
focused on so I don't think games
necessarily have to create inequality
there's only going to be so many winners
in a given video game tournament or in a
given tennis tournament or in a given
NFL or NBA league but I don't see any
reason why we you know can't all win at
for instance not being homeless or for
instance having a person that loves you
or having a good relationship with our
friends and family yes but first a very
brief theoretical point I agree with
some of my friends
not fully but like
varufakis
Jody Dean and so on who claimed that
what is happening today is that a
liberal competitive capitalism is
already approaching the end I think it
is Meaningful to say although the term
is may be too radical it's not as simple
as that that we are entering the ERA
with new federal Masters this Ultra Rich
corporations are owned by individuals
how did Bill Gates become so rich
he monopolized our comments if we want
to communicate we have to go through his
products so it's not profit in the sense
of exploiting his workers it's rent we
are paying him rent we are paying just
business rent and so on and so on so
this is a new phase but let me go to the
basic point about games I also agree
with both of you who got it correctly
that Earth there is no spontaneous
tendency towards equality inequality in
in games but they are contradictory in
what sense first
there is for me a strange psychological
fact that
uh
often you cannot say something in
reality but if it's put in the terms of
a game even theater play you can do it
for example the great classic Jane
Austen's Mansfield Park a young couple
is in love they are too constrained to
say this openly but they select
Shakespeare peace I think where they in
the game but they they can say it so
this is what jacquela comment I think
when he says that that the the truth has
the structure of a
and I deeply believe that in this sense
masks are never just masks when we adopt
a mask to play a game we can bring out
there something that we are not ready to
confront in our so-called in our
so-called real
life in this sense also let me give you
another example I'm ashamed to mention
it it's so stupid but you saw for
weddings and the funeral
that moment when Hugh Grant declares
love
you see
he does it in the sense of uh
you know he started repeating himself
but precisely through this apparent
breakdown of the game he gets his
message through
sometimes the failed game is the only
way to get the message through that's
why incidentally I hate male chauvinist
too when a woman reports to be raped
they say but you see she contradicted
herself and so on sorry but I would be
very distrustful if a woman were to give
totally perfect cold report on okay I
wouldn't discard it but you know what I
think sometimes the truth can only
articulate it through
failures and so on and so on so uh uh
the uh the last thing I want to I
emphasize this I don't believe in going
deep into your inner self sorry to be
brutal if you go deep into it you find
deep heat that I claim monstrous
fantasies and so on I believe that the
only way to
uh overcome yourself is to
identify with your mask to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas